[Music]
i'm doing excellent uh before we get
started uh daniel i just want to say
thank you for your work as james bond
i've really loved it and i just want to
say thanks oh you're very nice thank you
steve that's very nice of you
um so this is uh it's a real question
but uh hopefully fun um lashana you've
you're double 07. daniel you used to
play double 07. i guess i want to know
is uh who is the best double 07.
oh i don't
i was like it doesn't need to be a
competition but also
i see these heads
[Laughter]
it doesn't have to be a competition
thank you very much um listen
they're two different things aren't they
so they're always going to be two
different things but he's always going
to be my doublelift
and i'll leave it with that really
sure um i love learning about the behind
the scenes of the making of movies and
television shows and stuff that maybe
the fans wouldn't know what do you think
might surprise people to learn about the
actual making of no time to die
you know it's one of those things it's
like
you do a movie uh let's say a normal
movie it's the wrong word but it's just
we use it normal which takes three
months to shoot
ordinarily roughly um and a lot happens
in three months over
the two years that it takes to make a
bond movie from start to finish
there is so many things that go on so
many things we blew up the bond stage
which is just part of the course um
[Music]
uh what else did we do i know and i
broke my ankle um
there is
you know
i tell you what is very different a lot
of you know
a lot of movies now are done on green
screen clearly because it's a simpler
thing
we still strive to make the movies as
real as possible of course we rely on
cgi more than we used to because it's
now pretty good and we can do so many
things with it but
we're in those locations on the whole
and if we're not we're recreating them
in the most extraordinary way um and
that's kind of uh uh
every you know i walk onto a bond set
even on this last one and every day i
have to pinch myself because it's it's
it's so exciting
desean i'm curious which of your friends
and family were most excited when you
landed a role in this movie
oh
i almost don't want to bring them out
because it's almost like a competition
for who screamed the loudest and they
were all really really happy and
they've seen my journey they know
who i am what i strive for and how hard
i work and
how much this really was a surprise that
this even came into my inbox so um
i guess i guess i could just put my mom
up there because she was the only one
very very cool
yeah
she's cool and it's very like oh yeah i
knew this would happen yeah just go
there and just have fun it's all going
to be fine everyone was more chill than
i than i thought i was the one that was
like what's happening we've got to get
to work i've got get stunts i've got to
make sure i'm in shape i've got to make
sure i'm eating right and they were like
those things are going to be provided
just just be chill and just enjoy it
which i did so job done
i already have to stop i'm just going to
say again congrats on this movie
fantastic daniel again thank you for
your work
you're great thank you
you